it started off simple so he was like I
need a building where they had like kind
of a warehouse or production it's about
one building okay outgrew that bought a
second building
and he's from this very small town
Hamilton Missouri I think it is and um
so you know she buys two buildings and
then at some point they kind of realize
all right why do this with like nameless
faceless warehouses what if we could
turn this into content or marketing like
the YouTube channel is working so what
if we do kind of YouTube behind the
scenes and what if we make this more
interesting so instead of just buying
two warehouses and then just like you
know
operating in stealth
what if we just bought all this land and
we bought all the buildings that are in
this area and we turned this into a
tourist destination a vacation basically
so like it's a themed town in the middle
of nowhere but it's like the quilting
Mecca or like people call it like the
Disneyland for Quilters and there's like
12 like Main Street is all about quilts
this is like quilt shop quilt shop
[Music]
all right what up we got uh Ben Levy
here Sam is out today
but uh my business partner Ben so we got
producer Ben who's Ben Wilson and then
we got business partner Ben Levy and uh
Ben is here today we got a bunch of
topics that we want to talk about but
first welcome to the Pod yo what's up
Sean how's it going man
I'm good your your dad who's a regular
listener is going to be pleased because
he's going to hear you on here and I'm
sure he he always sends you like uh like
a huge text message of notes every time
you come on or is that right yeah it's
more like six emails he'll be like hey
did you hear Sean say this thing or did
you hear Sam say this or Sue we say this
and I'm like love the notes dad
so you were just in San Francisco
um last week and we did a bunch of
meetings we hung out worked a bunch and
then we hosted a Meetup we hosted a
private dinner
um I wanted to start with that so I
wanted to start with give me as many
nuggets of interesting things that that
came up people you met stories you heard
products you heard about whatever you
got from your trip to San Francisco I'll
let you take it from take it away
yeah so the first the first thing that
comes to mind is when San Francisco's
awesome uh but two went to the went to
the Warriors game so we went to the
Warriors game on last Monday with this
guy named Al Doan who I think he's been
on the Pod about nine months ago so for
people that don't know Al is the founder
of a quilt company and he said one thing
Sean I'm sure you could talk more about
Al but I think the one thing that he
said that was pretty by the way by the
way Ben just said quilt so uh because
you said it in passing I think people
wouldn't even it wouldn't even register
what you just said it actually the way
we met Al was pretty interesting Patrick
Campbell came on the Pod and Patrick
cable runs like a he had profit well
which like does like sass
uh payments or analytics and all that
good [__] so he has data on what
companies are crushing it in terms of in
terms of
um their subscribers and their payments
and he had said he had told us that
quilting is a huge Niche and he came on
the Pod he mentioned quilting and from
that we found Al Doan who basically runs
a
multi-hundred million dollar quilting
business that he co-founded with his mom
so so that's the setup but uh continue
yeah I think his mom and like his four
brothers and sisters so it's a family
it's a family affair uh so we hung out
with him last time we hung out with him
was Camp MFM and I think Al's an
interesting dude one he's like six seven
uh so he like Skies over you at every
time I see him I think he could have
played in the NBA uh but he said one
thing that really you know one is
business is doing great but two the
thing that he said that really raised an
eyebrow for me was he's in the Harvard
Executive MBA program uh so most people
when I when I hear the word NBA I think
immediately that it's stupid uh I just
think it's a waste of money and you
should go build something instead of go
get an MBA but he was like yeah I just
hung out with the air of Crystal Geyser
water so the place of the water you know
basically every water bottle you ever
see in the airport or convenience store
and Sean and I were both like wait how
do you know them and he what he said
like I think he said the the woman is
like you know basically it's an old
French couple or something like that
like he's like yeah I was hanging out
with my friend my friend she's French
she's she's older and blah blah and I
was like how do you have this like old
lady French friend where did that come
from he's like oh I did this Harvard NBA
thing and Al's like personality is not
what you would connect with Harvard MBA
first of all he does a quilting
e-commerce business so that's you know
like not like uh Fancy Pants you know
Harvard thing second he's this big dude
with a beard who lives in the Midwest
and his he's like super funny he's
basically like you know Will Ferrell
slash Vince Vaughn and uh and so you
just don't see him as a you know as a
suit but he did this suit thing and we
were like was wait is that a good idea
should I be doing that that was my
takeaway from it yeah I was like we
should definitely be doing that and I
looked it up I think it's like a fifty
thousand dollar a year program they take
like 30 people and everyone in there has
a really successful business so
definitely should be doing that I think
he said it's all people whose business
yeah I think like the minimum bars like
your business does 10 million a year
um so like you know that's like the
minimum uh sort of like Norm he goes
it's people from all around the world
because International people
like value Brands higher like if you've
ever seen a Louis Vuitton store that's
just full of Chinese people it's like
International people really love
American luxury Brands and Harvard is an
American luxury brand and he's like you
know it's I think he said it's three
weeks a year for three years or
something like that he's like but dude
you make the best friends like you know
the people who I you know not everybody
but he's like I made a bunch of Amazing
Friends through that and uh he's like
dude I'm in the middle of nowhere
Missouri so I gotta do things that will
connect me with other people and then
even this trip to SF we're like oh what
are you in town for he's like well I
live on a farm in the midwest so my wife
is you know down for me to just like
take three days a month and just go to
wherever SF New York La just meet up
with friends and hear what's going on in
the world so I don't stay like totally
disconnected in my bubble
yeah so yeah I think that was awesome
that he does that uh by the way you
should tell the tell the Missouri Star
uh because you you wrote this newsletter
uh on our personal newsletter yesterday
about owl and uh you should tell the
tell the highlights of his story yeah no
the thing that you didn't mention
earlier about Al is the way that we met
him is Patrick Campbell mentioned them
and then I think I just dm'd him and I
said hey do you hoot and no other
contacts then that was it and I was like
I've never met you but do you want to
come hang out uh North Carolina
that's a weird question why did you ask
that did you know he was tall or how did
you or did you just take a random shot
like do you play basketball come to our
basketball camp I think I looked on you
I watched a YouTube video like I I heard
of him I looked on YouTube watched like
a minute video and I was like he looks
tall seems like he has a good
personality in this one minute clip I
found on YouTube so hey let's just get
to business do you play basketball and
then he was like yeah I'll come and he
was like I have no idea who you I could
barely know who you guys are but sure
I'll guess I'll fly there and see what
dab
yeah and he was amazing um but his his
story is pretty cool so basically I
think that the short version the thing
he wrote in the newsletter yesterday if
people go to dismiss my name.com so
seanpuri.com you can sign up for the
newsletter you'll get this it'll it'll
send you the story after
a couple emails so
the story is his mom takes up quilting
as a hobby
and she's just having fun she's quilting
and then she wants to do I guess like
whatever is a more advanced quilt where
you like you gotta like send your thing
into a machine quilting company is that
right like how does that work certain
certain quilts you got to send in
yeah I think there's like certain things
that just need machinery and there was
like I believe there was a six-month way
to get some machine built quote machine
built uh quilt made and he was like oh
[__] there's a business here how is it a
six month wait
and it was just like there's too much
demand uh and so he's like Mom forget
this quilt like you need to like and
they bought the machine they're like
let's create a Service Company where we
do this because it sounds like there's
too much demand so they bought the
machine and then they make the website
where they're like oh yeah send us your
stuff and we'll do the machine you know
quilting thing for you
and uh and then people started asking
them for fabrics and so they started
selling Fabrics people started asking
them for patterns they started selling
patterns fast forward they've built this
company it's called Missouri Star
quilting company and again does you know
nine figures a year in Revenue
profitable bootstrapped family business
co-founded with his mom uh they sell
they have like 30 000 fabrics for sale
now on the on the website and I was like
dude what was the
what was the Turning Point like did this
work right away and what did he tell you
he like he's like well I started he like
posted on Facebook like hey guys made
this quilt website for my mom check it
out yeah like two likes yeah and I went
back and looked at all of his Facebook
posts yesterday and it's like I started
a quilt company buddy and that was like
his milestone in his life 15 years ago
and they must have figured something out
well it sounded like the thing that made
it take off was he got his mom to start
making YouTube content so he was like oh
YouTube was like still pretty early at
that time he's like um all right Mom
record videos teaching people like how
to be better at quilting
and she they now have the number one
quilting Channel almost a million
subscribers and Jenny who's his mom is
like beloved like the comments are just
like Jenny is the best she's still
wholesome oh my God I love her she's a
she's a star so the YouTube thing took
off and then he went and stole the idea
from woot.com about having one crazy
daily deal so something that's like 50
to 100 off but it's limited quantity
limited time and they call it the
quilter daily deal or something like
that and that trained people to just
keep coming back to the website to see
like you know what amazing deal could
they get for some new pattern and those
two things were like pretty major
um you know like growth hacks that they
pulled off to to grow this thing and he
might just be the most successful like
daily deal site ever right like in terms
of profitability yeah
yeah I don't know how big Groupon is now
but like you know it's it's what he did
is bigger than woot so you know that
that kind of worked and then the other
thing he told us about was his town so
explain this town and what he told us
like he's thinking how he thinks about
these Town things Yeah so basically uh
when we we discovered Al we realized
that he had a town it was written about
an NPR uh a few other places and
essentially what it is he had he needed
a bunch of production done so he needed
a manufacturing facility for all the
clothes they were selling so they bought
a town basically that which means they
own a few restaurants I think they own a
few gas stations and they own a few
manufacturing facilities and they made
it the quilting capital of the world so
basically it's where people go and they
want to learn and see learn and use
quilts and they also so he's basically
like really basically I think he's the
pioneer of towns I think he talked about
this in the Pod a while back but he's
all into towns and he yesterday he was
texting us even more ideas about towns
well it started off so he's like I need
a building where they had like kind of a
warehouse or production it's about one
building okay I'll grew that bought a
second building
and he's from this very small town
Hamilton Missouri I think it is and um
so you know she buys two buildings and
then at some point they kind of realize
all right why do this with like nameless
faceless warehouses what if we could
turn this into content or marketing like
the YouTube channel is working so what
if we do kind of YouTube behind the
scenes and what if we make this more
interesting so instead of just buying
two warehouses and then just like you
know
operating in stealth
what if we just bought all this land and
we bought all the buildings that are in
this area and we turned this into a
tourist destination a vacation basically
so like it's a themed town in the middle
of nowhere but it's like the quilting
Mecca or like people call it like the
Disneyland for Quilters and there's like
12 like Main Street is all about quilts
this is like quilt shop quilt shop which
then and then they have like the
Missouri Star one which is the biggest
store so that's their retail flagship
store they use this to create content to
create interest people then like take a
pilgrimage a trip to go visit here if
that's their main hobby if that's their
big hobby it's like oh here's the here's
the vacation I want to go on and when
they're there they also have a man what
is called man's land it's basically like
if you're the dude who got dragged to
this quilting vacation they have one
area called man's land which is like
really comfy recliner chairs TVs food
and it's just like yeah you hang out
over here and watch football and let her
you know let let Grandma go crazy at the
the quilt shops and so uh creating that
town I think is kind of amazing he said
that they have a hundred thousand
tourists come there every year which is
which is you know still kind of
relatively small but he's like yeah dude
we just need like a developer to build a
hotel like there's just no place to stay
and he's like you know nobody knows
about this area but I'm really he's
really bullish on turning the the sort
of the cost center into a marketing uh a
marketing tool and I think that was
really really smart and what I wanted to
tell everyone about the time that you
were thinking about yesterday
well we asked him we were like dude
that's I was like dude that's genius
what else would you do he goes got it
babyville USA I was like what and he's
like uh so he's got four kids or he's
about to have his fourth I think and uh
and he's like yeah basically I think you
could make a town for all things baby so
let's say you're a pregnant mom or you
just
um you just delivered you're in your
maybe you have a newborn a one-year-old
a two-year-old so most you know
traveling is hard first of all
uh for either late pregnancy or or you
know early kids
um
and nothing is optimized for them like
even places like Disneyland and like
places that are like kid friendly it's
like ages three and up really is like
what's what's like acceptable and useful
and so he's like dude if we made this
town where you could come and it's like
some combination of like just a crazy
Spa for Mom mom deserves it like she is
her body's going through a lot she's not
sleeping not all this stuff let's take
care of her let's have the best sort of
most baby friendly places whether it's
restaurants uh retail whatever it is
let's basically let you try any baby
products so like there's like the the
mass stroller store where it's like
you're gonna get the best stroller we're
gonna it's like you have the Consultants
there you have a testing ground
um you know this is where you're gonna
find the best products and you get to
test them you get to learn about them
and it's like it's like an expo for all
things baby so you're gonna sell a ton
of product you're gonna uh provide a
vacation or a rest you're gonna be the
most baby proofed and Baby Friendly
everything is gonna be optimized for
that type of clientele and you can also
do a bunch of fun things so he's like
dude stroller races uh you know he's
like you know we can he's like this
would be such amazing like funny content
uh that you could do around this whole
thing baby so he's like baby Phil and uh
and it's it's kind of true because like
we just hired a guy and he's like oh
yeah can I start after this date because
I'm uh I bought my wife a push present
and a push present for those don't knows
like you know after you deliver you
basically
so here's a gift or a vacation
um you know to celebrate you know
putting yourself through one of the
hardest things ever which is like you
know labor and um and so I think baby
moons are a thing push presents are a
thing I think there's already a whole
bunch of like the culture around this
stuff uh and so if you made the
Instagram worthy town for that I think
that could be big I'm I'm really hoping
he does this because uh I want this you
know and I want the baby combine I feel
like I'm so competitive and so many of
my friends are like yeah I don't care
about my my how I stack up to people my
age but I care like you know what
percentile is my son in height and
weight and how fast is he and is he
crawling I remember when when my son was
like one we would just watch other kids
on Instagram and decide who looks like
they're in better shape yeah just
compare yes I think that's a great idea
and I still yeah a baby vocabulary
contest baby crawling contest yeah like
crazy horoscope thing where we we give
you a scroll that tells you the future
of your baby for for a hundred dollars I
could think of a million things to sell
in this town yeah I love that uh and
like all right what else so we had Al we
go to the game what else did you got uh
another guy that I met up with was this
guy Justin called back uh so for people
that don't know Justin call back I think
is one of the best angel investors of
all time he led the Snapchat C deal uh
Pinterest seed deal uh he does have kind
of a checkered past uh so I think he was
essentially canceled uh so he was at
White Speed was basically canceled I
don't know three to four years ago and
now he's writing seat checks uh as a PR
as a GP
um so I basically met up with this guy
uh had talked to him a bunch on Twitter
and he said a few things about investing
that I thought were particularly
interesting and particularly that we're
thinking about the first was a question
which was like are you a good investor
uh and what's your answer to that Sean
like do you think you're a good investor
I think I I think two things
you can't know yet so I can't say with
anything definitive because
you only get measured I don't know seven
years after you start investing so the
honest answer is I don't actually know I
do think I will do well with investing
because I have a good Network
I have good judgment when it comes to
what startups have legs and what don't
um and uh and like you know I'm
aggressive so like you know I what I
make what I lack in IQ I make up for in
like uh guts and so um so I think those
three will result in uh in a great
outcome for me
and then the other question that he kind
of asked is like can you what did you
say when he said that by the way that's
a great question to ask somebody to be
like are you even good at what you do
um is it is a fantastic question what
did you say did you uh did you did your
butt clench in did you know what to say
in that moment uh I said
I don't think I'm great I think I could
be great if I tried he said that's what
everyone says
um and I said yeah but I think I could
uh and then he was like well okay answer
me these questions then can you defend
every deal that you've kind of pushed
the table for without saying these two
words grade founder uh he was basically
like I hate when someone tells me
they're investing because it's a great
founder because that's the that's
something that nobody can argue you on
uh even if they know the person because
they're just like I can argue you and
work it I can argue you on product I can
argue you on
um you know 10 other things but I can't
Darby you I'm great founder so can you
defend every deal you've done recently
without saying those two words uh what's
your answer to that question
uh can I defend every deal uh yes I can
explain why we did every deal would I
defend every deal no because I think
we've made mistakes along the way and we
did deals or deal sizes or add
valuations that knowing what I know
today I could say you know that that
wasn't a good decision you know uh going
back with the benefit of hindsight I
would think about that differently now
but I think that's natural like there's
no way that you could get into anything
as a uh you know start a new activity
new job new hobby whatever it is and
from day one be Flawless hell no right
now could you but should you have a
um a line of thinking on everything you
did yeah here was my line of thinking
was my line of thinking always correct
no uh here's some errors I made and I
can tell you specifically like three
errors I made one I would say is the um
oh but I love this business I hate the
valuation but I love this business
um I think that is a is a pretty common
mistake and even though it sometimes
works out like um you know we invested
in a company that was valued at 200
million I invested because I had been
trying to invest since the seed round
but I haven't gotten in so I kind of had
I was like you know anchored to this
lower price
and now it's a multi-billion dollar
company so our investment's still up I
don't know 40x so it's a great
investment from a return point of view
but honestly it was a pretty dumb
investment like my only out uh was that
this thing would this company would go
from 200 million to a multi-billion
dollar company even though at the 200
million I thought it was overvalued
based on where the revenue was and I
think even though I think I got lucky on
that more so than that was the correct
decision
um and I think that's the case for like
a bunch of things I did where
the difference in your outcome when you
invest at a eight million valuation
versus 18 versus 50 versus 80.
um is is just really really profound and
the better move is to stay disciplined
don't chase the higher valuations just
pass even on a good deal because you
just want to deploy all your dollars in
at the lower valuation so that you can
have when you hit you hit super super
big
um you know we did another investment
that was at a five million valuation and
now it's at I don't know 300 300 400
million and uh
it maybe it may end up at the same
multiple as the first deal I talked
about but the second one was actually
using Sound Logic and judgment and the
first one was uh chasing uh you know
something that I wanted and you know I
only had one possible way to to get a
good outcome out of that
yeah I think that yeah I think I think
that makes sense and I think he thinks
similarly like I think you know the
other thing that he said uh that I
intuitively knew but never really
thought about is how many deals he looks
at a week yeah he's talking to a hundred
to 150 Founders every single week which
I think is just like to do maybe one
deal a month at most so maybe he's doing
one out of 600 things he talks to
um and the thing that he said that I
thought was interesting about that was
uh you know you kind of notice what good
and great is you know most there's a ton
of people you meet that are in the good
category in terms of Founders right it's
like really smart people building
interesting things great backgrounds but
there's very very few people you meet
that are great
um so I think that was like a learning
for me which is like really being
disciplined to only do deals when you
think they're great which I think
applies to more than just Angel
Investing kind of applies to everything
it's like most of the time you know what
crate is uh but you just get impatient
and you go for good
right and I think his his portfolio is
pretty nuts by the way GrubHub snap Open
Door Stitch fix whatnot imperfect Foods
uh uh boom Aerospace you know these are
these are some some pretty solid ones
especially if we got in there yeah and I
think you know I think obviously he was
canceled there me too for a reason so
like I don't I don't I can't say he's
like the best dude personally but
obviously he's a great investor yeah
yeah you know it's hard to know what
happened in certain situations and I
don't know I try to
for better for worse my thought when I
meet people is when somebody tells me
how great somebody is I don't assume
that they're perfect and when somebody
tells me how horrible somebody is I
don't think that they're evil and
terrible
um I sort of take people at face value
so I meet them I uh you know ask them
about the situation I hear the story and
then I see how they treat me and I
observe how they treat other people
around them and I kind of just use that
as my filter rather than
um getting caught up in this sort of
stuff and I also have friends that I
think are like you know
um great in one area of their life and I
can learn a lot from them in that area
uh you know whether it's investing or
business or Fitness or whatever and
they're not so great in other areas of
their life rather than sit there and
judge them I just try to if I find
somebody that's great I want air life I
just focus on that and I try to learn
from them on that and I move on you know
I don't really get too caught up in the
full picture
yeah 100 and then in terms of you know
other thing I I took away from San
Francisco was there was one other thing
that we did that I took a lot away from
which was we had a small dinner with
about 10 people uh I had no idea really
what to expect like I I went in cold
basically knowing none of these people
uh
so Sean you want to set the table for
what that dinner was like yeah we hosted
a dinner at F dot Inc uh which has a
great office in um
in Fort Mason and San Francisco
uh we invited about 12 13 people
something like that
uh I would say some of them knew each
other but most people didn't so it's one
of these like Stanford very San
Francisco things it's like one person
curates the guest list and they're
basically saying trust me these people
are cool
and then everybody else just goes on
that uh that assumption and if you ever
violate that it's like dude I went to
this one dinner this guy hosted and
people were not cool you're just like
all right they're out but as long as you
can successfully curate this you can
sort of build a really cool community
and brand around it so inviting some
people uh the conversation was basically
I think you know I saw your face at one
point because in the most San Francisco
thing possible the conversation quickly
shifted to like drugs but like not like
uh party drugs but like um
you know people in Jefferson love this
like you know sort of like oh I micro
dose this thing or I do Ayahuasca or I
do DMT or I do
um mushrooms you know for productivity
and like all this other stuff like I do
this instead of therapy I do this in
addition to therapy I do this in
addition to or to help my productivity
and it's like bro could you just drink
coffee like why do we have to do all
this are you sure that's like my feeling
because I'm I'm like a a more Straight
Arrow guy like I just I don't do I don't
do any of the stuff but that was you
know that was pretty heavy part of the
conversation at the beginning and then
there was you know it transitioned from
there but what was your take on the uh
the drug convo
yeah I mean you know I've been someone
that's always I haven't done anything
but I'm not like incredibly opposed to
it I you know my take was just seemed
like that's what most people were
focused on like uh every most the people
in that room were really successful and
the thing they were focused on was
figuring out in some ways how to be
happier uh like that's kind of what it
boiled down to is like how do I be
happier and how do I have better
relationships with the people that
matter uh and it's always odd to be in
you know I always find it kind of uh odd
to be in those rooms where everyone
seemed like they have everything they
possibly want right like I'm probably
the least wealthy person in that room
the least well-known person in that room
and uh yeah so I find it interesting
that people are resorting to that type
of thing and maybe there's a lot of
great to be had uh the other thing that
I took away from it is everyone talked
about this thing called touchy feely
which is a thing that happened I think
it's like a Stanford class where
basically you boil a leadership class so
if everyone's talking about how to be a
better leader uh and how to really
connect with people and the one thing I
wrote down in my phone was I'm an
[__] so I remember like basically the
their take was this is like really when
all these things boil down to is
recognizing that you're the [__] at
every situation uh then I remember
afterwards I was like I don't know maybe
I'm just an [__] for to everyone for
these 10 reasons I think the line was uh
every great marriage comes down to one
realization I am an [__] and once you
realize that and you accept that it
humbles you but it also uh it's sort of
like you understand the other person's
side because damn they're dealing with
this [__] and I thought that was like
a really I don't know if I believe that
but I thought it was a great line
um there was one part on the so the the
drugs part I thought was interesting
because it was like
some of these things that are taboo
today become very normal 10 years from
now and Silicon Valley is usually at the
front of that curve and you're right it
was stunning I mean this is a very
successful group of people there wasn't
a person in that room who wasn't wealthy
successful all that stuff and I would
say what
40 of the people at that table had
experimented with some version of a like
I don't know what you would call the
hallucinogenic type of drug in order to
try to be happier uh you know happier
less anxious or better in their
relationships and um that's just a crazy
ratio to me you know that's a that's a
wild ratio that's a very San Francisco
uh a ratio that you get and sometimes
San Francisco is just off the reserve
off the reservation and sometimes
they're ahead of the curve and it's
pretty hard to figure out which ones
which you know these are the same people
that in you know 20 2012 we're talking
about Bitcoin and this is the same group
of people that you know um
whatever they're like you know
experimenting with AI four or five years
ago
um you know so they are the the hard
part is you can't write it off because
often these are people that are that are
right in a bunch of areas
yeah the touchy feely thing I thought
was cool because they said that one
framework for communication uh I think
that's probably worth worth saying which
was uh so they're talking about how
great this touchy-feely thing is and of
course my natural question was like wait
so like like what like what did you like
what's an example you're saying how
great this was and how it changed
everything for you like what's an
example and uh our friend siki uh siki
Chen who now runs Runway
gave this great uh framework he goes
they teach you that there's what was it
five layer five layers of communication
and so let me see if I can remember this
off top of my head so he's like the
first one when you deal with people
you're gonna be at one of these five
layers so it's like uh the level one or
layer one is ritual this is like you
know you walked you walk into the office
hi hey hi you know hey what's up what's
up you know like just like it's
automated it's not like it's just a
ritualistic thing you're just a quick uh
quick hello then there's number two
which is extended ritual which is hey
how's it going how's your day uh you
know what's new these things that you
you say it's an extended version of the
ritual you don't really care or you're
not really asking the question you're
not really expecting anything
nor are they really telling you what
going on in their life it's sort of this
uh like just this dance we do
the third level is you're talking about
some content but it's surface content so
at the third level service content is
you're talking about a project you're
talking about
um something you're working on or
something you're doing uh something
that's happening you're talking about
the game you're talking about the the
project whatever it is
um and what he basically said was like
you know most of our communication just
happens at these three levels every day
but the problem with it is
um imagine in every interaction there's
two tracks so on the on your left hand
is the track of like the content of the
conversation and on the right is the
relationship between the two people and
at these first three layers the content
might be moving but the relationship is
not moving uh relationship the
relationship uh is not being invested in
and so if you want to be somebody who's
better at building relationships like
you don't you need to get out of just
these first three layers and get to
number four four and five four is
feelings about the content so
how do you feel about what's going on
right I feel stressed about this project
I feel worried about this thing I feel
so excited about uh this game tonight
you know whatever it is and you're
sharing a little bit about what's inside
for you how you're feeling about the
thing not just talking about the thing
so that's that's better that moves It
Forward because you're there's some
vulnerability there and then the last
one is feelings about each other which
is
dude you know I felt disappointed when I
expected this was gonna happen but
actually this happened or I felt uh
annoyed or I felt
frustrated that we keep ending up in the
same Loop and being able to share that
is obviously the the the saying how you
feel about the other person and I said
negative ones but it could also be the
other way like you know I feel you know
I love working with you I love uh all
right you know I had so much fun I felt
uh you know tons of Joy when we were
doing XYZ so you could sharing how you
actually feel about the other person is
the hardest one but when you do it
that's what moves that other track the
furthest and uh and they talked about
like the little nuances like instead of
saying I feel like blank blank blank
anytime you say like you took it away
from how you actually feel it's just I
feel blank or I felt blank
um is the right way to do it so I
thought that was pretty cool because
that stuff it's hard to learn anywhere
like school or whatever and it sounded
like that you know you talked about the
Harvard Business School thing that was
one note and the other one was the
Stanford touchy-feely thing as like oh
that sounds pretty cool uh I should
check that out or you know I want to get
better at that
this data is wrong every freaking time
have you heard of HubSpot
HubSpot is a CRM platform where
everything is fully integrated well I
can see the client's whole history calls
support tickets emails and here's a test
from three days ago I totally missed
HubSpot grow better
and you told a great story uh basically
about your experience doing that same
thing uh at the prison you already
should tell that story
yeah so
all right so once uh once upon a time I
uh I get an email from my boss and this
is a guy uh Michael Burch so he was
basically the main investor in our
company and he's kind of like my mentor
when I moved to Silicon Valley I moved
here to work with Michael Michael uh
Bert she built multiple successful
internet companies that's what I wanted
to do so I was like I want to learn from
this guy and um I always I don't know if
other people feel this way but whenever
I'm around somebody who I really admire
or I really like like
I feel an intense pressure to
um just like do good in that do good in
that setting like I just always wanted
to like put my best foot forward uh if
it was a meeting I wanted to look smart
if it was a socialist situation I wanted
to be Mr Charisma and like be the be
this they brought me to this event I
want to have the best conversation and
sometimes that's okay that's natural but
often it felt forced and it's just a lot
of stress so anyways he emails me this
thing says hey come with me to this uh
this I did this event and I want you to
come to it you know don't ask too many
questions just come he's like it's
Friday at this time to show up and so I
show up
and what he signed me up for was uh this
group called inside Circle I think it's
called and basically they take a group
of
kind of like Silicon Valley CEO type
people a group of men from from the
business world and they bring them
inside of Folsom Prison and they take
you to meet inmates who are uh in prison
for life so they have a life sentence
and
um so you go to this sort of like I
don't know if it's maximum security or
whatever but you go to this like intense
prison and you're going to meet with
people who are in prison for life if
you're in there for life you did
something that's you know Murder or you
know sort of equivalence and and so I'm
like oh [__] and he's like yeah it's a
two-day event it's like an overnight
event I was like what the hell uh all
right thanks Michael so I go to this
thing we walk in and um I don't I still
don't really know what to expect I'm
like are we giving a talk is this like
an entrepreneurship talk like what are
we trying to do here so I'm prepared for
like some presentation or something like
that but instead we walk in
uh the guys all get uncuffed we all walk
in together
and um we all sit in a circle and I'm
like oh this is a feelings thing oh [__]
this is like you know this is like AAA
or something I don't know what I got
myself into but my brain is racing and
when the guys were walking in uh you
know I'm like just kind of like scoping
everybody out and there's one guy who
walked in
that just stood out right away he was
wearing sunglasses and he had a cane but
he wasn't blind so I was like I don't
know how this dude has this privilege to
like be able to have a stick that he
walks around with and sunglasses
but this guy's got clout immediately you
could tell and he was the only guy who
was like not smiling not talking to
anybody he had like two guys around him
who like kind of escorted him to see
brought him a clip of water and I was
like oh [__] this is the guy who like
runs the prison got it I've seen movies
about this [__] I know how to like spot
the alpha this guy's the alpha
and so
the event basically starts as follows
they go break them into like smaller
circles uh you know groups of six and um
and you know this guy who's been here
he's the facilitator he'll begin so
break up into group of six of course I
get paired in a group with this sticky
the Tough Guy and um I'm like all right
what do I have to do here how what do I
do again what am I trying to trying to
do to like you know do well in this
situation
and basically the group was sort of like
the the activity was sort of like you
just each person goes around you just
say what's on your mind
first guy gets up and he tells this
super intense situation that he's in
he's like
uh right now I'm feeling
um
frustrated man I'm feeling pissed
feeling angry I'm like oh [__] he's like
I'm feeling angry because uh my daughter
who's on the outside told me that you
know she had been sexually assaulted and
I'm pissed that I'm not there to beat
that guy's ass and then you know protect
her and uh and so this guy tells us like
really intense thing and then I'm like
oh [__] and then the next guy says an
even more intense thing and third guy
says this really traumatic he's working
through this really traumatic experience
by the third person I'm no longer
listening I'm in my head and I'm I'm
doing the math I'm like okay I'm three
people away what am I gonna say and like
I mean look at me I'm wearing a Mickey
Mouse shirt right now I'm like you know
my parents love me my life is pretty
good I'm healthy I'm happy and all of a
sudden I'm like God damn it parents why
did you have to love me I don't have
[__] to say here like I I couldn't you
have just had a drug problem and made
this a little easier for me like what am
I supposed to say that's not gonna stand
out like a sore thumb like I can't be
like the biggest problem in my life
right now is we have this deadline for
this thing we're trying to this new
feature we're building by Friday and I I
just don't know if we're gonna hit it
guys like you know that shit's not gonna
fly here so I'm like [__] [__] [__] I'm
panicking and I'm not listening at this
point it keeps going around the circle
finally it gets to me
and I'm like okay I just gotta tell this
like this kind of like this the most
traumatic thing that's happened in my
life whatever I guess I'm gonna say it
to these strangers and I'm gonna ham it
up a little bit and really like you know
just try to deliver this I essentially
start performing and so I I tell this
thing about some family thing that
happened in my past and I'm like doing
these dramatic pauses and I'm like you
know
not like pretending to cry but I'm
definitely pretending to feel it a
little more than I was actually feeling
it in that moment
I tell the story and I told it good I'm
a good Storyteller and so I'm like I
brought my a game because I was under
pressure I told a great story
and I'm like all right thanks you know
thanks girl for listening and uh on to
the next and then the hard guy goes
man that's some [__] and I was like
oh no what what's happening and I go
what and he goes man that's some
[__] man you're just saying that
[__] I go no that really happened
because I don't care if that happened he
goes you ain't really feeling that and
so this guy basically instantly sniffed
me out in a way that very few people can
really tell
you know when I'm bsing like that
and now I'm feeling like am I gonna get
beat up like what's gonna happen here
this is a worst case scenario the hard
guy is like just like went out of
nowhere he didn't say this to anybody
else in the group but for me he's like
that's some [__] man and he was like
out he was like out on me and he goes he
said something he goes like um
he goes
I go what do you want me to say he goes
he goes I want you to say what's on your
mind uh well yeah what you really
feeling and I go
I'm feeling nervous because why I go
because
um
I want you to like me like the truth
came out I was like I want you to like
me which is it was the honest and I'm
like oh my God what did I just say the
lamest
possible thing that one man can save
another
hey pause and he goes
that's your truth
and he like accepted it he goes that
show truth man and he got up and he like
got it he like came up to me whatever
and we like whatever uh he's like you
know I appreciate you for telling your
truth that he hugged me and he sat back
down and I was like what just happened
he's laughing now this guy had it
cracked a smile the whole time and he
just thought it was so funny that
obviously he scared me shitless which he
did and uh he got me to break which he
did but it also showed me like like you
should just uh lead with the truth it's
a lot easier than uh trying to perform
but uh yeah that was my like
touchy-feely uh touchy-feely like
intense experience
yeah that's basically what touchy feely
is right it's just like trying to get to
the core of what you're actually feeling
or thinking right and sharing it
yeah I mean I don't know I haven't done
it but it does seem like it's about
being a little more more honest more
authentic and less of the surface level
autopilot [__] that like we get used to
doing kind of in the real world
um
all right what else we got so that was
your San Francisco trip any other big
ones otherwise let's do a couple of cool
ideas the last one from San Francisco is
uh the other person that came to dinner
was this guy named Kendall so he bought
the milk Road uh with Mike uh some milk
craters a crypto newsletter and then
Sean and I started and sold and I think
from I worked with them for three months
pretty Hands-On every time I see him it
makes me think of this which is you know
instead of asking what would a g is this
still I asked what would Mikey Kendall
do uh and they do two things really well
that I try to embody whenever I ask that
question which is like one one Kendall
himself is really good at spotting an
opportunity so he's basically he's
thinking and fishing all day to find
what they should go attack and then Mike
is really good at consistent intensity
uh so what I mean by that is let's say
you're trying to figure out Facebook ads
every single day first 10 hours he'd be
looking at it try to see what's working
what's not and doubling down instead of
being like Oh Facebook's working I'm
gonna go work on Pinterest now I'm gonna
go stand up a Twitter ad so I think when
I saw Kendall it just reminded me like
be more of Kendall and Mike uh in
anything because that's a winning
combination to be like great at spotting
things and then once you spot something
that you want like take in incredible
intensity to get it done
yeah so these guys each have basically
you know candles builds and sold
companies for something like just under
100 million dollars two companies uh my
slash company I think sold for nearly
200 million dollars so obviously very
successful but when we met them
you know I always look for okay what
what was it about this person what what
contributed to their outsized outcome
because
usually the [__] ain't an accident uh
you know we always you got to have some
attributes so it's like what are the
attributes that this person had that led
them to that some people it's they're
amazing Engineers okay great they built
some crazy [__]
some people it's like um they're amazing
investors they are great at spotting
opportunities
um and and whatever for some people
they're great
um sales people you know oh this guy
could sell ice to an Eskimo I can see
how they were able to grow their
business really fast
uh so this person you know somebody's
really high IQ they're just super super
smart they you know they they built this
thing that I could barely understand
half the words about you know but they
understand that industry they navigated
it
with Mike and Kendall I felt like with
Kendall I was like you wouldn't want to
compete with this guy
because he's just gonna figure out the
loophole in the game like he's gonna
figure out the cheat code I think he's
gonna figure out oh and Mario you run
onto this block that you just hold down
and then you fall behind the screen you
run and then you get The Magic Flute
that lets you skip nine levels and I
feel like that's Kendall Kendall will
find The Magic Flute that lets you skip
levels whereas you're sitting there
trying to beat every single level and he
he was just like no that sounds painful
I'm gonna find you know I I think I
heard or you know there's got to be this
like solution where I can get ahead
faster what is that who's making the
most money and then how do I do what
they're doing so he's he's good at
sniffing out that thing and Mike is like
um
Mike is smart but he's not like
he's not like he's the smartest dude
I've ever met but he is one of the most
intense dudes I've ever met like uh
we'll have a meeting and then we'll go
out for drinks but somehow in between he
ships like a a notion doc with all of
the action items tagged and like
referenced uh because he's like well
obviously that was a good plan we should
write it down and then do it and I'm
like yeah well don't say it like it's
common sense like you know oh we're
gonna get a little distracted over here
and we're gonna you know we'll stretch
it out we'll procrastinate a little bit
he's like well why would you
procrastinate just do the whole thing
right away it's like I don't know
because I'm not you I'm not a machine
and he's a machine and so I think it's
really useful to just be around somebody
like that and I think we had this Theory
when we sold the milk road to them
because we were considering different
offers and it was like I don't know dude
I think we're not pro like it's hard to
put a price on we're gonna get to hang
out with these guys who are going to
make us better as entrepreneurs that's a
factor and um and so yeah they I think
we've noticed this in a bunch of people
as we meet people me and Ben always call
each other in debrief after meetings and
I think one of the more common ones is
they have this like an intensity is
often the most common
trait that we're seeing in these
successful people because they're so
different in all these other ways but
the one thing they have is like once
they see an opportunity they're pretty
effing Relentless and focused on doing
it they don't procrastinate they don't
wait around they don't uh you know half
do things or quarter do things they like
overdo things and uh they do it like the
intensity knob is is cranked past the 10
they broke the knob and it's on 12. uh I
feel like that's been common for a bunch
of people that we've we've hung out with
over the last few years
yeah yeah and I think like now that I
see grade I'm like okay I wasn't great I
could be great yeah he's great
right right uh that's true the other one
that was funny was uh
we bumped into Rahul ligma at the
Warriors game so if people don't
remember this uh when Elon bought
Twitter
there was this guy that went and he was
standing outside the Twitter office with
a giant cardboard box and he was like uh
yeah I'm a data science engineer at
Twitter I got fired oh yeah Elon came in
he fired me and you know and then the
reporters were like oh tell us you know
what what are your thoughts on Elon and
and how does it feel to have this and
he's like you know he says so this guy
didn't work at Twitter it was a giant
troll uh and he's friends with some
friends that we have and he he had sent
a text like an hour earlier being like
dude there's hella people outside of
Twitter I'm just gonna take a box and
pretend I got fired you want to come and
him and his buddy went took an empty
cardboard box and tricked reporters from
CNBC and all these places there's all
these articles about with these these
guys featured he said his name was Rahul
ligma as in you know ligma these nuts
and uh and like you know there's another
guy Daniel Johnson so it was ligma and
Johnson who were pretending to be to be
fired and so they kind of went viral in
Silicon Valley as like silica Valley
loves when people you know try the media
or beat the media or point out that the
media is stupid and the media loves the
opposite they love to point out when
silica Valley is stupid and overrated
and over hyped and over funded and all
this stuff it's like a little war that
goes on
um and so Rahul was like he won he won a
key battle in that war and so we're at
the game I'm like dude that's that's the
guy that's like again he's a random
engineer startup founder that nobody
knew like you know a few months ago and
now he was sitting courtside at the
Warriors game with two like billionaires
and he was just hanging out and I was
like you know this guy probably went to
college studied hard spent 150k getting
a degree you know I was trying to make a
startup successful and the thing that
like catapulted or like a random
inflection point in his life that
catapulted him was this random troll he
decided to do and I think that's just
kind of amazing and very uh I don't know
there's a lesson to be learned in there
what was your reaction to that yeah one
I thought the troll was incredible like
I think one you know I'm not an anti-big
media guy but I have seen you know when
you're on the inside of a story and what
they you know how they spin it to make a
great headline uh so I have one great
troll by the way the best part of the
Troll he's holding up a Michelle Obama
book it was a cardboard box and he had a
the Michelle Obama book and then they go
what do you think about you know getting
fired under Elon you know is was that
right and he goes this would have never
had happened under Michelle Obama which
makes no sense that's so funny yeah and
they didn't somehow pick up on that that
this guy is just a you know this guy's
lying yeah so good I don't think he's
just like do things that make no sense
like I think a lot of a lot of stuff I
try to do like makes no sense why you
would ever do it uh you can't like map
it to anything going forward you're just
like oh it sounds fun and funny so [__]
it like let's do it
yeah we've talked about that before the
do cool [__] budget which is do you have
a budget of both money and time that you
allocate towards things that don't have
a clear Roi except for that sounds fun
or like dude that would be hilarious or
that would be that that's amusing or I
don't know like I've never done that
before and I think you know the way
Google had Google had 20 time where
basically if you worked at Google you
could spend 20 of your time on anything
that you thought would just be cool for
Google
um so they you know they're like hey
we're gonna pay you in one fifth of your
time you can spend not on any project
that we assign you or that has Roi and
like Gmail came out of that and Facebook
had these hackathons that were the same
thing it's like these late night
hackathons to take away a bunch of
productivity from Engineers but they
were like you know this is fun this is
good for culture and good [__] can come
out of this that we can't predict and
like you know the like button was built
during one of these hackathons for
example you know with the like button is
obviously you know massive for Facebook
and so I think that everybody should
have this do cool [__] budget so how do
you put take 10 to 20 of your time and
your money and put it towards things
that are just for you know shits and
giggles um I I know I do that uh I think
we should do that with our companies I
think everybody should really do that
yeah I mean the one thing I try to do
consistently is just talk to a bunch of
random people that you know there's no
real Roi but a lot of interesting stuff
comes out of all those conversations
yeah you should explain how you do that
because
um I gave you access to my Twitter and I
was like I don't know I get a bunch of
DMs I can't keep up with all this and
you kind of took that and turned it into
an asset so like what did you do and you
you basically just blocked off like what
Thursdays or something where you just
have back-to-back rant like full random
meetings with people that you think are
interesting with no agenda is that like
that's my read of it yeah man I think
you know a long time ago I started by
basically saying oh uh people think Sean
is awesome so how do we DM them and just
get on calls and meet interesting people
and have no agenda and just shoot the
[__] uh so we're just DM people and say
what's up this thing is awesome uh and
you get like a 90 response rate
sometimes it is a little weird because
people will be like thanks and then
you're like all right I don't know what
to do with that but don't have people
give you an opening they're like oh cool
dude what's up and uh so I would be like
how do I pour those into conversations
to talk to as many random people as
possible over time I started to do it
from my own account uh and the main idea
is just like No Agenda talk talk to
someone about what they're working on
ask a bunch of questions almost every
single time uh I learned something that
I didn't think about before whether it
be like oh wow this company is huge or
this thing they're working on is
actually way more interesting than it
appeared than it appeared when I first
saw it uh and then I try to send them
interesting things as I see them on
Twitter like I think my best one of my
best skills is I'm always on Twitter see
interesting things that I just send it
to a bunch of people and over time it
tends to lead to good outcomes uh like I
think almost everything I can count to
or like say in my life is because I'm
good at that on Twitter yeah like when I
think of oh this person is great at
networking I think about you know
you know some like I don't know tall
dude is good at shaking hands and making
small talk and like you know some smooth
Operator politician type dude and
that's not you're an amazing networker
but you are you do nothing like that and
your method is first of all it's all
online
uh secondly you're just like
you I feel like you don't overthink it
uh if I was to kind of reverse engineer
what I think is good what you do that's
good is you find interesting people you
compliment them on what they're doing
that's interesting
you then send them things that are like
kind of helpful like oh did you see this
or check this out or you might like this
or dude I met this guy you should talk
to him and you just like
add Little Nugget one two three and by
the third nugget they're like what I
like this Ben dude this guy's this Ben
guy is all right you know he seems to he
likes me and he's helpful to me and like
therefore you're interested in them and
therefore they're interested in you
whereas I think I always took that
reverse approach which had terrible
results which is I want you to like me
so I'm going to tell you all the
interesting things about me
and like no matter what how interesting
I am I'm nowhere near as interesting to
them as they are to themselves and I
think you do an amazing job at like just
being interested in them and being like
helpful not asking for anything in
return and uh that's how we met and then
that's how I feel like you've built
for all the people I meet you end up
with a better relationship with them and
so there's something you're doing that's
amazing and I'm trying I'm still trying
to figure it out I think the other thing
is like introducing them to other great
people like I think that's always an
easy win to be like you should you're
having this problem meet this person who
can help you uh that's like a great way
to do it and then College I used to be
like oh I just need to always check in
and see how someone is doing for them to
like me and want to talk to me like now
someone did that with me I'd be like bro
what do you want me to say like I'm good
uh or I'd be like oh you went to Duke I
should write that in my notes and like
send you an email when Duke wins a
basketball game then I kind of realize
like what are you gonna think you know
like what would if someone said who you
know it every time the sun's on a game
or I'd be like okay like what do you
want me to say like thanks for like
thinking of me that the sun's on a game
uh so I was like how do I just actually
understand what they want and like when
I see interesting things just send it
and maybe it's useful maybe it's not but
they know I'm thinking about them in
that moment
goes a long way
Julian Shapiro has an interesting
version of this that he does that I kind
of love which is he'll just send you an
email with one image in it no no subject
line no text and the images of random
meme but it's like Julian's sense of
humor is really weird and so it'll be
like a picture of a parrot and then in
the on the on the parrot's chest it says
look in the top right corner and you
look at the top right corner it says not
this one the left corner you go to the
left corner says not up here idiot down
there you look down it goes go to the
right corner you finally go to the
bottom right corner and it says I love
you and it's like he'll send you that
and nothing else or he'll just send you
like eight straight random images of
like you know I don't know whatever
gorilla is eating cake and you're like
Julian what's going through your brain
right now and I don't know what this is
but it makes me laugh and it's just
different and it's like it's really
quick and easy for him to do this and
it's like I don't know who this guy is
but he's interesting and he's fun and he
makes me laugh and like he does this
like you know we talk about these things
that like Sam does his you know let's
[__] when he gets into town and he he
wants to meet somebody who he only knows
online or he's friends with
um and that's just like a better like
more fun version of like let's hang out
uh Julian's like random meme thing is
interesting uh your your thing where you
send little helpful nuggets of hey did
you see this I think that works too
everybody's got their own style but uh
you know the style I think doesn't work
is me me me me which is the the style
that I had originally taken which was
like well I'll just focus on what I want
and what I think is cool and then people
will be interested in that it's like no
not really yeah and for a while I'd be
like you know in college there are a
number of people to teach you in college
like oh make a LinkedIn post about your
internship you're getting a lot of
people are gonna care or like send
people updates on what you're working on
I'm like
I don't know who cares that I got an
internship at Walgreens you know and
like if someone sent me that I'd be like
instead send me something interesting or
cool or ask me an interesting question
or like uh send me something you found
interesting about what I'm doing uh
that's way more I think that's way more
valuable than like what the other person
wants right right we should add this on
a few ideas we should do like five
minutes of Rapid Fire ideas okay you go
first
uh first idea I've been thinking about
is something related to your d2c
business which is wholesale like one of
the things I think been thinking about
is wholesale so for people that don't
know basically you have a Shopify store
you want to sell more in micro micro
Boutique so let's call it uh the local
clothes store in your city right now
that's really hard to do so I've just
been thinking about someone could build
something in a space that makes it
really easy uh we talked to a company
doing this that basically makes it
really easy to spin up and run your
sales Channel as it will say anything to
add to that one
uh that's a great idea and a no-brainer
we have a person in our for our econ
brand who we have one person dedicated
to kind of doing this process it's very
manual it's like find a list of all the
mom and pop boutiques uh great now reach
out cold in this script and it's all
managed through Gmail and or you know
some sales tool and then you know so
like sourcing them
um reaching out to them managing the
payments and invoices
um keeping track of your analytics who's
actually who's do who's a big spender
for you who's uh who's falling off and
churning you should reach back out to
you know all that stuff making it easy
for them to shop uh because they're
buying in bulk all that stuff I think
can be uh I would love a tool that does
this and uh by the way we should reach
back out to that company that we talked
to about this and be like hey we gotta
do this
yeah all right give me give me one of
your ideas let's do two more all right
you told me about
um
nil which is the college
um name and likeness thing we're
basically College athletes can now get
paid so up until now they couldn't get
paid now they can get paid uh to do you
know appearances or merch or different
things like that
um I love businesses that are built
around rule changes or Law changes
because it takes something that was
impossible and now makes it very
possible and there's great examples of
this like Oscar Health was built as soon
as Obamacare came out
um and so
uh one I think that somebody should do
is if I'm like you know 21 years old or
whatever I'm 18 years old right now I
would be like all right
I now have access to a bunch of
influencers that are in college that
want to get paid and the marketplace is
not efficient yet meaning they have more
sway than they're priced at just because
people haven't abused this channel yet
so I'm gonna be the one to abuse this
channel I'm gonna be the one to grow
like crazy off this the way that the
movement watches guys
built a luxury watch brand using kind of
cheap watches uh because they were like
yo Instagram has these people who are
popular influencers we should send them
all watches and pay them to to promote
and they built 100 million dollar watch
brand before Instagram influencers
became a big deal
um
so I think somebody should do this and
it's like all right you should work
backwards from what do who follows
College athletes and
what do they need so let's let's assume
for a second that it's other college
students at that college or fans of that
college that follow them what could I
sell and so what are the best products
and so you know maybe it's Financial
Services I like credit card type stuff
or maybe it's like a beverage brand like
an energy drink because I remember in
college like people would drink Red
Bulls at five hour energies staying up
late studying I think you could create a
new five-hour energy off the back of nil
or you could create a new condom brand
like I don't know how big Trojan or
directs that these brands are but you
know they've been around for a while
they're kind of stale and they don't
they're not that fun and I think
somebody could build the uh the college
conda brand or the college energy drink
brand using these nil influencers yeah I
think in general nil like uh I tried to
book someone before using like open
doors which I think today is like kind
of the winner of the nil Marketplace
basically the idea of I can book someone
on demand for anything whether it be an
appearance autograph etc etc I think
there have has to be a startup out there
that is doing this now in a really good
way locally so we should find that
startup too that like is attacking the
nil Marketplace in a different way right
uh all right that's gonna be it for the
Pod thanks Ben for coming on and
actually if you um if you like Ben you
want to see some of the stuff one thing
he's working on right now is we took
every episode of my first million so
we've done
400 plus episodes now
um and we had somebody go through and
pull out every idea
every framework and every tool that's
mentioned
um and we're categorizing it we put it
all into a giant air table so that you
could basically see like what are all
the ideas they had and then you could
sort by like you know the ideas that
were you know
um all about
AI or all about crypto or all about SAS
or you know side hustles right for
example and
then I took the top 10 for each both
Frameworks and ideas and I'm writing
about them and expanding them and saying
you know here's the idea here's what I
would do uh for each of those and we're
putting it together so this is going to
be uh like I don't know some super PDF
type thing so if you want that go to
um go to my website go to seanpuri.com
drop your email in and um you know I
don't know how long it's gonna take us
to finish this maybe another week or so
but uh that's where that's where I'm
gonna send it out so um so go there sign
up and if you want basically to take the
best of from the Pod and then kind of
update uh you know I'm gonna update and
give my commentary on on the sort of the
best ones uh from there so I think
that's gonna be an awesome resource for
people if you're a fan of the Pod
um you know I don't know it's no brainer
it's kind of a must must have if you've
been listening all the way through
there's no way to keep track of all the
different ideas that we've we mentioned
on here so so I think that would be
that's going to be awesome so I'm
excited about that thanks for being for
coming on and uh again I'll put the link
in the in the description on YouTube and
in the podcast but it's just
seanpreter.com and then you can put your
email in in there all right guys uh
thank you for uh thank you for listening
that's it that's the point
[Music]
thank you